ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen die
USA und Großbritannien haben in der
vergangenen Nacht Stellungen der hui
Miliz im Jemen angegriffen sie reagieren
damit auf die Attacken der hui auf
internationale Handelsschiffe im Roten
Meer laut US-Militär wurden mehr als 60
Ziele an 16 Standorten beschossen
darunter Kommandopunkte Munitionsdepots
und Startanlagen für Raketen die
Angriffe sein sowohl mit Kampfjets aus
der Luft als auch von Schiffen und
U-Booten aus durchgeführt
worden ja die hui milit die kontrolliert
weite Teile im Jemen wird von Iran
unterstützt und sieht sich als
Verbündete der Terrororganisation Hamas
seit Beginn des Gazakrieges greifen die
hui immer wieder internationale
Handelsschiffe an bei denen Sie eine
Verbindung zu Israel sehen wir wollen
heute deswegen fragen welche Folgen hat
die Eskalation im Jemen wie effektiv ist
der Militär Schlag und was bedeutet das
für die eh schon extrem angespannte Lage
in der Region darüber spreche ich gleich
mit dem naostexperten Robert chataji und
mit dem Sicherheitsfachmann Moritz BRAK
der lange aktiv in der Marine war unter
anderem im Kampf gegen Piraten eure
Fragen und Gedanken zum Thema könnt ihr
wie immer gerne direkt im Chat mit uns
teilen oder ihr schickt sie uns per Mail
an die eingeblendete Adresse
zdfute-li@zdf.de ja und aus Berlin ist
mir jetzt Robert Chatt zugeschaltet er
ist nost Experte und stellvertretender
Chefredakteur des Magazins zenid guten
Abend nach Berlin ich grüße Sie Herr
chatag sehen wir da gerade eine neue
Eskalation der eh schon angespannten
Lage ja was wir gesehen haben ist eine
Operation vor der man das Gefühl hat
dass sich die angreifende Seite die
westliche Koalition da irgendwie
gezwungen gesehen hat irgendetwas zu
machen wenn man ein bisschen genauer
hinschaut dann stellen sich doch sehr
viele Fragen wie wohl überlegt und
koordiniert das überhaupt
war und auch ob man nicht auch das Spiel
der hothies ein bisschen mitspielt und
ob man diese Ziele die noch gar nicht so
richtig so genau formuliert sind damit
überhaupt erreicht und das gilt sowohl
in militärischer Hinsicht aber auch
natürlich in politischer Hinsicht ich
glaube ganz grundsätzlich
setzt man sich da auch mit einem Gegner
ein der glaube ich sehr viel besser
versteht was er eigentlich genau will
als die westliche Koalition das wollen
wir im Laufe dieses Streams noch weiter
vertiefen sie haben es jetzt gerade kurz
angesprochen also war das was wir in der
vergangenen Nacht gesehen haben aus
ihrer Perspektive ja nur eine Frage der
Zeit bis es zu einem solchen Angriff
kommt ich glaube man hat sich dort schon
sehr unter Handlungszwang gesehen gerade
nachdem in den letzten Tagen und Wochen
auch Angriffe intensiver wurden und auch
in bestimmten Branchen
auch deutliche Folgen schon zu spüren
waren insgesamt weil war man eigentlich
war ich eigentlich überrascht dass es
nicht früher schon solche Folgen gegeben
hat das liegt auch ein bisschen daran
dass man mit der Unterbrechung von
diesen Handelswegen in der Region
durchaus in den letzten Jahren ja schon
ein bisschen Erfahrung gesammelt hat
etwa im Nachgang des ukrainekriegs
insofern sind andere Alternative
schissfahrtruten für große Redereien
etwa ums Kapp der guten Hoffnung
durchaus auch schon im in der Lage sowas
teil Weise abzufedern aber natürlich nur
zu einem bestimmten Grad und ganz
wichtig ist es dabei natürlich auch zu
schauen auf direkt betroffene Länder
besonders die beiden anreiner Ägypten
und
Saudi-Arabien genau wir wollen im Laufe
deses Streams natürlich auch noch weiter
darüber sprechen jetzt hat sich
US-Präsident Joe Biden heute auch noch
mal zu dem Angriff aus der vergangenen
Nacht geäußert und er hat dabei
folgendes gesagt da können wir einmal
raufschauen und zwar sagt sag er
wörtlich ich werde nicht zögern bei
Bedarf weitere Maßnahmen zum Schutz
unserer Bevölkerung und des freien
Flusses des internationalen Handels
anzuordnen sagt der US-Präsident also es
war offenbar ein groß angelegter Angriff
sie haben jetzt gerade in Frage gestellt
wie gut und wie wohl überlegt und
koordiniert der jetzt wohl war also ein
Angriff der Amerikaner und Briten ging
es ihre Einschätzung dabei wirklich
darum ja ein Zeichen zu setzen sozusagen
bis hierhin und nicht weit und ja kann
das funktionieren das denke ich schon
ich denke es ist ein vor allen Dingen
symbolischer Schritt ähnliche
symbolische Schläge haben US haben die
US- schreckkräfte in letzten Jahren oder
in früheren Jahren ja auch schon mal
durchgeführt ohne dass sie wirklich
verbunden waren mit einer größer
angelegten kohärenten
Militärstrategie eher einem
übergeordneten Ziel ich denke auch dass
man eine Art Abschreckung herstellen
will ich glaube ich glaube es ist schon
zu bezweifeln ob man das ähm gelingt
tatsächlich wenn man sich das mal
genauer anschaut was dort genau passiert
ist und wer daran beteiligt war stellen
sich doch ein paar Fragen vor allen
Dingen auch bei den bei dieser Koalition
die da
die da beteiligt war ja Herr ch dann
entschuldigung wenn ich da unterbreche
dann lassen Sie uns da gerne einmal
drüber sprechen ich möchte es einmal für
alle die jetzt zuschauen einmal ergänzen
und zwar diese dieser Angriff aus der
vergangenen Nacht der erfolgte eben
maßgeblich durch die USA und
Großbritannien aber mit der
Unterstützung durch die Niederlande
Australien Kanada und
bachrin was sagt diese Koalition was
sagt das für sie aus warum war aus
dieser aus der Region dort abgesehen von
bachin sonst niemand daran
beteiligt das ist ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt bachinen taucht da als
unterstützender ST vor allen Dingen auch
weil das US Kommandozentrum in der
Region ja in bachrein stationiert ist
und ansonsten fällt natürlich ins Auge
dass kein einziger anderer Staat auch
keiner der Verbündeten St Staaten dort
in irgendeiner Weise
beteiligt ist ganz im Gegenteil einige
der Staaten haben ihre Sorge und auch
ien Widerstand
über diese Aktion geäußert vor allen
Dingen z.B auch Saudi-Arabien direkt
Betroffener Staat der seit geraumer Zeit
ja auch in Verhandlung ist weil man ja
seit fast einem Jahrzehnt dort auch im
Krieg mit den Husi sich befindet ich
glaube auch in Ägypten ist die Sorge
doch sehr groß dass dort dass man dort
ein ein neues Konfliktfeld schafft
wovon man überproportional dann
betroffen sein wird aber wenig Einfluss
drauf haben wird und selbst auf der
westlichen Seite fällt doch auf dass
einige Länder dort nicht auftauchen die
sich auch schon davon distanziert haben
z.B auf europäischer Ebene sind das etwa
die Italiener die ganz klar gemacht
haben dass sie diesen Ansatz nicht
unterstützen was die Amerikaner dort und
die Briten aber vor allenen Amerikaner
halt wollen ist ein bisschen auch analog
zu dem was US- Außenminister Anthony
blinken in dieser under vergangenen
Woche bei seiner Tour durch den Nahen
Osten tun wollte nämlich eine Art
Koalition der Willigen zu schmieden und
bei dieser Militäraktion
ist ihm das offenbar ebenso wenig
gelungen wie eben auch
in anderen Feldern etwa bei der
bei der Suche nach
Lösung konstruktiven Ansätzen nach
Partnern in der Region für die Gaza
Krise genau das wäre nämlich meine Frage
gewesen also wir haben gerade das Zitat
vom US-Präsidenten Joe Biden gemeinsam
gelesen also die Angriffe werden eben
begründet mit der Bedrohung für den
internationalen Handel viele Redereien
also der der Handelsweg durch das Rote
Meer gilt als eine der wichtigsten
Handelsrouten der Welt viele Redereien
haben eben auf die ja Bedrohung durch
die HU Miliz reagiert und schicken eben
schon seit Wochen keine Schiffe mehr
durchs Roten Meer durchs Rote Meer
halten Sie diese Begründung von den USA
eben den internationalen Handel zu
schützen für glaubwürdig oder geht es da
wie sie gerade schon kurz angerissen
haben möglicherweise um
mehr ich glaube die Sorge ist auf jeden
Fall berechtigt und die Teilen nicht nur
die USA sondern natürlich viele andere
Länder und natürlich auch die gesamte
schiffahrtsbranche
und auch viele
viele Branchen die von der Logistik und
von diesen Logistikketten abhängig sind
die Frage ist ob das wirklich ein
effektiver Schritt ist dort für mehr
Sicherheit zu sorgen und inwiefern auch
der Gegner mit dem man es da zu tun hat
wie weit man den wirklich nachhaltig
davon abhalten kann in Zukunft auch
weiter diese Nadelstiche zu setzen so
würde ich das
schon bezeichnen was die hui Milizen und
indirekt damit auch das iranische Regime
und sein
vasalenystem ja machen ist mit relativ
geringem Aufwand ohne seine wichtigsten
ohne seine wichtigsten Instrumente
eigentlich zu verpulvern doch
nadelschichte zu setzen und relativ viel
doch zu erreichen und auch
so ein bisschen die strategischen Gegner
auch zu binden
die Iraner haben ja auch gerade durch
diese massenhafte Produktion etwa von
von drohen doch in ganz vielen Feldern
gerade auch im Jemen für die huthis dass
das Feld ein bisschen begradig ein
bisschen egalisiert das heißt ähm so
eine Antwort eine
eine Antwort wie man mit so einem Gegner
umgeht ist ist da natürlich total
essentiell und das alles ist ja noch
nicht wirklich
geschehen und solange das jetzt nicht so
etwas nicht geschieht sehe ich da jetzt
nicht mehr als einen symbolischen Schlag
der natürlich irgendwie für Abschreckung
sorgen soll ich bin aber sehr sehr
bin aber nicht überzeugt dass dieses
strategische Ziel weiter erfüllt
stattdessen denke ich besteht schon eine
Gefahr dass man sich dort noch größeren
Handlungszwang eben aussetzt sollten die
husis einfach weiter operieren und dann
z.B auch zu anderen Waffensystem etwa zu
drohen
Zurückgreifen auf dem man die man eben
nicht diese Antworten hat wo man jetzt
nicht irgendwie die schahrappen für
Raketen irgendwie abschießen kann und da
steht man noch mal für viel größeren
Fragen mhm das heißt ich verstehe sie
richtig dass sie durch diesen Angriff
aus der vergangenen Nacht jetzt kein
eine sozusagen wesentliche Schwächung
der husim milit sehen nein ganz im
Gegenteil gerade wenn wir über das
militärische mal
hinausblicken können die huthis
natürlich jetzt für sich beanspruchen
als eine Art ideologischen Sieg dort den
eine einer westlichen Koalition und dort
die Stirn zu bieten also das S ganz
klassische Koalition die es auch in
früheren Jahren Jahrzehnten schon
gegeben hat und den man eigentlich nicht
noch mal auf den Leim gehen sollte
insofern ähm wirkt wirkt aus meiner
Sicht das wirklich sehr naiv und man hat
auch glaube ich vor allen Dingen aus
westlicher Sicht glaube ich nicht
wirklich ein Gefühl dafür wie nicht nur
diese Aktion allein für sich gesehen
sondern auch im Zusammenspiel mit mit
der Politik und ganz konkreten
Schritten in der gazarise in der Region
gesehen wird und deswegen versteht man
auch nicht warum es einem einfach nicht
gelingt dort mehr Partner a seine Seite
zu bekommen denn das hat ganz konkrete
Ursachen lassen Sie uns über die
Auswirkungen auf die Region gleich gerne
noch einmal sprechen davor noch einmal
kurz die Frage also die die huthi haben
heute als Reaktion auf diese Angriffe
Rache geschworen ihre Einschätzung nach
wie könnte die konkret
aussehen na ja die huthis sind nicht die
gleiche Gruppe wie z.B die hiszbollah
die über ganz andere Netzwerke auch noch
mal verfügt es ist eine vergleichsweise
lokalisierte Gruppe die wirklich nur im
Jemen äh operiert die natürlich auch zu
Ausbildungszwecken auch
woanders woanders mal ist aber im
Wesentlichen in dieser Region operiert
und in dem Sinne für die Iraner z.B
beweiten nicht so wertvoll sind wie etwa
die hbollah die ja direkt an der
israelischen Nordgrenze sind und die man
auf jeden Fall nicht nicht opfern möchte
für eine Auseinandersetzung von der man
das Gefühl hat dass man sie vielleicht
nicht für sich entscheiden kann
zumindest zu diesem Zeitpunkt und Rache
heiß in in in dem Maße dass man dass man
seine seine seine Angriffe durchaus
glaube ich auch intensivieren wird da
glaube ich ein bisschen auch die
Anpassungsfähigkeit unter Beweis stellt
denn man sollte sich natürlich auch
fragen wie kann es so eine Gruppe
schaffen eben sich auch so lange dort zu
halten die hthis sind eine relativ
kleine und obskure Gruppe gewesen die
Anfang der 2000er im Jemen aufgetaucht
ist und die Tatsache dass die sich in
diesem kom plexenfeld dort relativ
clever manövriert haben ist nicht ein
ist nicht einzig darauf zurückzuführen
dass es nur iranische wasallen sind und
wenn man und wenn man das nicht erkennt
dann wird man glaube ich es auch sehr
schwer haben
dort irgendeine Art von von Erfolg auch
vorweisen zu können und ich habe die
Befürchtung dass man sich noch viel zu
wenig eben tatsächlich ehrlich mit
diesem Erfolg der huthis im jeemen dort
auseinandergesetzt hat und dann findet
man natürlich auch schwer eine Strategie
etwas dagegen zusetzen Herr Chat vielen
Dank für den Moment wir wollen gleich
dann noch mal sprechen auch über die
Auswirkung und ja eine mögliche
Eskalation des narostkonflikts und auch
über die aktuelle Lage die sie jetzt
gerade kurz angesprochen haben im Jemen
die auch noch einmal vertiefen vielen
Dank für den
Moment russland hat den Militärschlag im
Jemen der eben mit der Unterstützung ich
habe es gerade schon gesagt der
Niederlande Australiens Kanadas und
Bachrain durchgeführt wurde verurteilt
und eine Sondersitzung im UN
Sicherheitsrat be antragt international
gab es aber auch viel Zuspruch unter
anderem von bundesaußenministerin
Annalena berbock die Bundesregierung
stützt diese Reaktion politisch wir
haben uns als Bundesregierung gemeinsam
mit anderen Partnern entsprechend
geäußert die husis tragen die
Verantwortung für die Folgen ihres
Vorgehens die Angriffe auf die zivile
Schiffahrt sie müssen diese Angriffe
unverzüglich einstellen
ja kann die Sicherheit für die Schiffe
im Roten Meer so wiederhergestellt
werden aus Köln ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet Moritz brake er ist Experte
für maritime Sicherheit unter anderem an
der Uni Bonn war selber 20 Jahre lang
aktiv in der Marine und ist Mitgründer
einer Sicherheitsfirma die unter anderem
auch Redereien berät guten Abend nach
Köln ja schönen guten Abend Herr brake
die EU will offenbar in Kürze eine
marinemission zur Sicherung der
Schifffahrt im Roten Meer auf den Weg
bringen am Dienstag hören wir wollen
sich Vertreter der Mitgliedsländer
treffen um darüber zu beraten aus ihrer
Sicht
überfällig auf jeden Fall ist das ein
ein Feld in dem es eine internationale
Koalition braucht und die Europäische
Union ist hier direkt und in ihren
ureigensten Interessen betroffen sie ist
direkt nicht nur gefordert hier in einer
Verantwortung für die Seeleute die hier
mit Leib und Leben in Gefahr sind für
die Schiffe aber auch für die
internationalen See natürlich die von
denen Europa abhängig ist von denen auch
Deutschland direkt abhängig ist aber die
auch für die Stabilität in der Region
wichtig sind das heißt also hier
natürlich ganz klar auch ein Aufruf zum
Handeln an die Europäische Union hier
eben nicht nur in der Verantwortung in
der Welt und in der humanitären
Verantwortung tätig zu werden sondern
auch in der Verteidigung
ureigenster Interessen das ist sozusagen
der Schutz dann durch eine mögliche
Militärmission uns fragt aber jemand bei
Youtube und zwar Tom Tom 34b wieso
installieren die Handelsschiffe nicht
geschützeet zur Abwehr das hat do schon
im 17 Jahrhundert funktioniert was
antworten Sie
darauf na ja einerseits muss man sagen
technisch
ist das etwas was sich gar nicht so
leicht realisieren ließe und das andere
ist dass auch rechtlich Handelsschiffe
nicht einfach in dem Maße zu bewaffnen
wären wie es nötig wäre um mit
derartigen Bedrohung umzugehen die
Besatzung von Handelsschiffen sind auch
in keinsterweise darauf ausgebildet oder
darauf ausgelegt hier für Selbstschutz
zu sorgen also diese Art Bedrohung über
die wir hier reden das ist nicht einfach
irgendeine kriminelle Gefahr wir reden
auch nicht über die Gefahr von Piraterie
wie sie eben auch vor einigen Jahren in
der Region akut war und auch jetzt auch
nach wie vor wieder auch gerade
aufflackert sondern wir reden hier über
wirklich Angriffe mit militärischen
Mitteln auf Handelsschiffe auch mit
marsflugkörpern das heißt also das ist
definitiv etwas da kann ein
Handelsschiff mit den ich sag mal
normalen verfügbaren Mitteln gar nichts
entgegensetzen und man kann das von den
Besatzungen oder den rädereien auch
nicht erwarten was nicht heißt dass es
nicht trotzdem ein dringende
Notwendigkeit für technologische
Innovationen gibt um hier mit dieser
Herausforderung umzugehen nicht nur mit
marchnurkörpern sondern vor allem auch
mit dem was wir eben auch sehen viele
kleine Drohnen oder relativ günstige
massenhaft hergestellte Drohnen die zur
akuten Gefahr für Handelsschiffe werden
da gäbe es durchaus technische
Möglichkeiten um damit umzugehen aber
auch das ist natürlich ein Aufwand der
jetzt erstmal in der kurzen Zeit für
räereien sehr schwer zu leisten ist und
hier sind natürlich nicht nur die EU
sondern die Staaten die hier für die
Freiheit der sewege eintreten ganz klar
aufgerufen hier etwas zu tun dann lassen
uns gerne noch mal über die gerade schon
angesprochene marineemunition Marine
Mission sprechen so ist es richtig wie
könnte bzw wie müsste eine solche
Mission aussehen um eben die
Handelsroute im Roten Meer best möglich
zu
schützen eine solche Mission müsste
natürlich robust sein sie muss das wir
sehen gerade aktuell an dem wie die
Mission die von den Amerikanern ins
Leben gerufen wurde prosperity Guardian
in welchen aus Maß die Schiffe dort
gefordert sind also sie sind wirklich in
einer Rolle dort unterwegs wo sie die
Mittel die sie haben auch tatsächlich in
der Bandbreite zu Bekämpfung von
Luftzielen einsetzen müssen es sind also
einerseits Flugzeuge im Einsatz die
gegen Luftziele kämpfen es sind aber
auch die Schiffe selbst mit ihren
marchlugkörpern mit ihren Geschützen die
gegen drohen gegen angreifende
marschlugkörper agieren und das ist
etwas was ein solcher militärischer
Verband ein Marineverband leisten kann
dafür sind diese Schiffe gebaut
ausgelegt die technischen möglich reiten
sich da nicht nur in der deutschen
Marine sondern in den marinen in Europa
aber natürlich auch bei den Verbündeten
und das ist etwas was hier gegen genau
diese Art militärischer Bedrohung auch
diese Qualität der Bedrohung das einzige
Mittel ist was jetzt auch so kurzfristig
verfügbar ist wir haben jetzt gerade
schon bundesaußenministerin Annalena
berbock gehört uns fragt jemand bei
Youtube und zwar jumpi oder jumpi ich
hoffe ich spreche es richtig aus warum
beteiligt sich die Bundeswehr bzw die
deutsche Marine aktuell nicht an der
Mission
das ist natürlich eine sehr ja eine sehr
spannende Frage
die deutsche Marine hat genauso wie ihre
Verbündeten Möglichkeiten mit einer
solchen Bedrohung umzugehen aber
natürlich liegt auch hier Deutschland in
einer besonderen Herausforderung auch
aufgrund der eigenen ich sag mal
verfassungsrechtlichen Situation wie
kann man sich in so einer Situation
einbringen mit militärischen Mitteln ist
das ein Einsatz den man früher mal out
of area Einsatz genannt hat wo ein
Bundestagsmandat hat zur Mandatierung
Entsendung von Bundeswehreinheiten in
einen in eine internationale Mission
gefragt ist diese internationale Mission
steht aber ja in dieser Form noch gar
nicht das heißt also hier wäre in der
Sichtweise dass es sich um einen
Auslandseinsatz der Bundeswehr handelt
tatsächlich auch eine gewisse Hürde noch
da um die Voraussetzung zu schaffen dazu
müsste erst eine z.B eu- missission da
sein an der man sich beteiligen kann
eine andere Sicht allerdings könnte
natürlich auch sein hier zu sagen
dadurch dass hier die Freiheit der
Seewege in Gefahr ist und tatsächlich
auch Schiffahrt betroffen ist aus
Deutschland aber eben weil Deutschland
an den internationalen Seewegen auch
letztlich vital interessiert ist unserer
Überleben als Gesellschaft unseres
Staates unserer Wirtschaft hängt von
freien Seewegen ab also könnte man hier
sogar argumentieren sagen hier geht es
um nationale Verteidigung und der Bund
stellt Streitkräfte zur Verteidigung auf
das heißt auch hier wäre durchaus
denkbar anders auf eine solche Lage zu
schauen und zu sagen man schickt unter
nationaler Egede Schiffe hier aber das
ist natürlich etwas was es so bisher in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik auch
noch nicht gab das heißt hier würde sich
auch tatsächlich eine ganz neue
Herausforderung auch mit einer neuen Art
damit umzugehen für Deutschland
manifestieren wenn wir jetzt mal von
einer deutschen Beteiligung an dieser
Mission ausgehen mit welchem Gerät mit
welchem Schiff mit welcher Fregatte
könnte sich Deutschland denn an einer
solchen Mission überhaupt
beteiligen ja also es ist kurz vor
Weihnachten die Fregatte Hessen wieder
nach willmshafen zurückgekehrt sie ist
doch Teil einer einer natomission ist
damit auf einem hohen Stand der
Bereitschaft bestmöglich ausgebildete
Besatzung ein Schiff was technisch in
der Lage ist mit der Bedrohung
umzugehen das heißt also das wäre
sicherlich eine Einheit die dafür in
Frage kommt die auch grundsätzlich
bereit steht und auch relativ schnell in
in in eine solche ich sag mal in eine
solche Mission geschickt werden kann
oben drein kann man natürlich auch noch
sagen dass vorausgesetzt der letzten
Vorbereitung die dann immer noch nötig
sind um ein solches Schiff zu schicken
man immer noch mit etwa 14 Tagen rechnen
muss die das Schiff braucht ab dem
verlassen willhelsafens bis es unten in
der Region ist dass das also auch
natürlich Zeitfenster sind in denen auch
in der Vergangenheit politische
Rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden
können um dann wenn das Schiff Vorort
ankommt tatsächlich auch den Einsatz
machen zu können man sieht es in der
Geschichte der deutschen Marine der
letzten 30 Jahre dass immer wieder auch
diese Distanzen die überwunden werden
mussten um überhaupt am Einsatzort zu
sein genutzt wurden um das dafür nötige
politische dat dann auf den Weg zu
bringen und die großen Missionen die die
Bundeswehr in den letzten Jahren gemacht
hat sind alle in weniger Zeit oder sind
auch eben problemlos in weniger Zeit als
14 Tagen mandatiert worden das heißt
also auch hier könnte theoretisch
parallel gearbeitet werden um der
Dringlichkeit der Situation gerecht zu
werden und vor allem natürlich auch den
Verbündeten dort zur Seite zu stehen bei
einer Aufgabe die vitale Interessen
Deutschlands und auch Europas schützt
Herr Bracke eine Frage von Youtube würde
ich ihnen gerne noch mitgeben und zwar
fragt uns da jemand wird das Vertrauen
der Redereien denn wieder wachsen dass
sie wieder den Kürzeren Seeweg also
durchs Rote Meer nutzen oder werden sie
jetzt erst recht den langen Weg nehmen
müssen also einmal unten rum um Afrika
fahren was glauben
Sie für die räereien ist die Situation
extrem schwierig wenn man sich überlegt
dass natürlich dort das Leben der
Besatzung in Gefahr ist ist das etwas wo
ja wo man sehr sehr stark abwägen muss
welchen welchen Weg schlägt man ein hat
man die die Möglichkeit auf sich auf den
Schutz durch eine internationale
Koalition zu verlassen und da teile ich
übrigens nicht die die Einschätzung des
Kollegen die die vorhin
die vorhin kam es handelt sich nicht nur
einfach um symbolische Akte der
militärischen Präsenz oder der des
Einsatzes von Militär hier in dieser
Situation sondern es geht ja um den
konkreten Schutz vor konkreten Angriffen
auf Schiffe es muss also hier gelingen
zu verhindern dass vom Jemen aus
Angriffe ausgehen auf Handelsschiffe
oder aber zumindest mit guter Sicherheit
guter Wahrscheinlichkeit sicherzustellen
dass diese Angriff abgefangen werden
damit Handelsschiffe sicher passieren
können denn das kann man einem Seemann
auf einem Handelsschiff oder einer Frau
eben nicht zumuten dass dort diese
Besatzung durch ein Gebiet fahren in dem
sie wirklich ja um ihr Leben fürchten
müssen sagt Moritz brake Experte für
maritime Sicherheit vielen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung heute Abend live aus Köln
danke
schön ja wir wollen jetzt noch mal
darüber sprechen was die Eskalation im
Jemen für die eh schon extr angespannte
Lage im Nahen Osten bedeutet und darüber
möchte ich jetzt noch einmal sprechen
mit dem nahostexperten Robert chatti in
Berlin Herr Chat die USA haben heute
versichert man wolle nicht auf einen
bewaffneten Konflikt mit dem Iran
zusteuern der ja bekanntermaßen der
engste Verbündete der hui Miliz ist die
hui wird vom Iran ich habe es gerade
gesagt unterstützt und zwar finanziell
aber eben auch mit modernen Waffen lässt
sich eine solche Eskalation mit dem Iran
überhaupt
komplett
ausschließen na ja die Iraner möchten
keine direkte
Konfrontation deswegen hat man ja auch
dieses
vasalensystem aufgebaut und der der
große Trumpf der Iraner sind ja nicht
teure Waffensysteme sondern relativ
günstige Waffensysteme vor allen Dingen
diese
Revolution ein
bisschen man hat ja da teilweise von der
kalaschnikof der Lüfte gesprochen durch
den drohkrieg auf den gerade die
westliche Kriegsführung eigentlich noch
keine richtige Antwort
hat außerdem wollen die Iraner natürlich
die sind die Iraner natürlich auch ein
bisschen in der Zwickmühle gerade wenn
man sich ideologisch so aufstellt als
Führungsmacht als die führende macht die
sich eben auch aus eigener Sicht den
kolonialistischen westlichen Mächten
entgegenstellt
etc manövriert man sich natürlich ein
bisschen in so eine eine Ecke und
erzeugt natürlich auch so einen
handelsdruck die gr Befürchtung war
eigentlich eher für die Nordgrenze
Israel für die vor allen Dingen seitens
der hisbolla gerade nachdem dort auch ja
ein hochrangiger hamasfunktionär vor
wenigen Wochen dort ausgeschaltet wurde
etc und da ist do ganz klar dass die
Iraner das auch nicht wollen nicht weil
sie es grundsätzlich ablehnen sondern
weil die auch kalkulieren können wir
sowas gewinnen oder nicht das heißt auch
da wegt man ab wie viel setzen wir jetzt
ein und da ist die logischste logischste
Lösung in den letzten Wochen Monaten
gewesen einerseits Irak dort vor allen
Dingen auch
amerikanische streiträfte auch immer
wieder unter unter Beschuss nehmen und
halt im Roten Meer was den zusätzlichen
benefit in dem Sinne hat dass man da
auch noch ganz großen ökonomischen Druck
mit relativ geringen Mitteln
erzeugen kann
ich denke auch schon dass man das auch
nach diesen Luftschlägen auch noch
weiter tun wird deswegen habe ich auch
von einem symbolischen Schritt
gesprochen weil ich eben auch nicht
glaube dass die dieser dieser Luftschlag
tatsächlich diese Kapazitäten so
ausschalten wird und dass das über Nacht
so geschehen wird ich denke dass die
hutis bewiesen haben wie anpassungs
fähig sie auch
sind und dass man sie nicht
unterschätzen sollte und ich glaube dass
dass dieses diese politische und
militärische Strategie schon fundamental
ist und vor alleningen auch dass man
Partner an Bord hat das ist ja etwas was
die Amerikaner auch wollten aber gerade
jetzt ne wenn man dort im Roten Meer so
viel jetzt verlegen möchte dann braucht
man natürlich die Unterstützung z.B von
Ägypten Ägypten ist total betroffen
davon weil der Sueskanal ja eine ganz
wichtige Einnahmequelle gerade für
Dollar äh divisen ist und ähm da möchte
man auch nicht nebenbei stehen und dass
über über die eigenen Köpfe da irgendwas
entschieden wird was man selber gar
nicht beeinflussen kann und im noch
größeren Maße gilt das natürlich für
Saudi-Arabien im Roten Meer sind einige
der wichtigsten
prestigeentwicklungsobjekte der
saudischen Regierung man verfolgt dort
ein übergeordnetes zi natürlich von
Stabilität man möchte dort Investoren
ranholen Entwicklung etc und diesem Ziel
untergeordnet hat man auch ein ein Stück
weit diese regionalen Rivalitäten sowohl
was den Jemen anbetrifft da habst die
huis tatsächlich auch irgendwie
geschafft die Saudis quasi an den
Verhandlungstisch zu Bomben und die
husis verzichten natürlich nach solch
einem solchen Prestigeerfolg nicht auf
die Mittel die ihnen das ermöglicht
haben aber die Saudis wollen auch gegen
üüber den Iranern
durchaus eher deeskalieren weil man
möchte äh Stabilität Investition etc und
man teilt ja auch zu einem gewissen Maß
etwa mit den Iranern
sowohl eine Ablehnung zu starker
westlicher gerade amerikanischer
Militärpräsenz
aber eben auch durchaus dieses Unbehagen
was in Gaza vor sich geht da stehen die
SA ist ja auch ganz groß unter Druck
wenn man sich so als so eine große
Regionalmacht definiert und letztendlich
doch de facto so wenig Einfluss hat und
sehen wir so wen ich da machen kann
steht man da unter riesigen Druck und
jetzt schlagen die Europäer wieder ein
bisschen auf eigene Faust zu das kann
den Saudis natürlich
so nicht gefallen und solange man auf
diese Sensibilitäten nicht ein eingeht
z.B wird man auch dort die Staaten nicht
auf ihre Seite bekommen wenn man dort ne
in den Gewässern operiert die natürlich
wesentliche saudische oder ägyptische
Interessen betreffen und das ganz außer
vorlassen und zu sagen
unser primäres Interesse sind unsere
Handelswege und ich glaube das ist ein
ganz großes Problem was auch in der
Region jetzt gesehen wird wir denken
also wir im Westen denken wieder einmal
nur an unsere Interessen und handeln
auch nur wenn unsere Interessen oder
unsere Versorgung unser Wohlstand
irgendwie in Gefahr scheint Herr T sie
haben es jetzt gerade schon kurz
angesprochen Israel und Gaza welche
Auswirkung sehen Sie durch diese
Eskalation in der vergangenen Nacht die
Angriffe da am roten mehr auf die
Stellung der hui
für Israel und für den Krieg gegen die
Terrororganisation
Hamas ja einmal hat sich jetzt ein
bisschen natürlich auch die
Aufmerksamkeit wieder wieder ein
bisschen
verlagert ich glaube unmittelbare
militärische Bedrohung in dem Sinne so
nicht weil die Husi Angriffe sich ja
auch schon auch eher auf den
schissverkehr fokussieren nicht so sehr
wie das gerade am Anfang vom Krieg ja
auch befürchtet wurde durch lang und
Mittel Strecken Raketen die dann
tatsächlich auch so weit reichen können
ich glaube diese Befürchtung haben sich
so nicht ergeben aber klar ist die his
können immer Nadelstiche setzen und
setzen damit natürlich die gesamte
Region Unterdruck also eher indirekt und
das merkt man dann natürlich schon ich
denke ganz wichtig ist zu sehen auch
oder eine Perspektive zu sehen wie in
der Region das jetzt auch eingeordnet
wird wie es eben schon angedeutet habe
diese dieses entschlossene Vorgehen
jetzt steht halt für viele Menschen in
der
Region im Widerspruch und da sieht man
das so ihr im Westen ihr ihr Amerikaner
ihr Europäer sobald eure Nachschubwege
eure Versorgung also ein bisschen
gefährdet ist schließt ihr euch zusammen
und schlag zu aber beim be bei dem was
in gas passiert wenn dort 10tausende
Menschen sterben dann eben nicht und so
wird auch
ganz viel auch das öffentliche Auftreten
jetzt z.B der Außenministerin gesehen
die ja auch gerade in dieser Woche vor
Ort dort noch mal in der Region war die
war glaube ich gerade vorgestern in Gaza
und dass sie da gesagt hat dass es
medizinische Katastrophe ist das wird da
gar nicht mehr wahrgenommen sondern ganz
im Gegenteil man hält das man hält da
natürlich den Spiegel vor und den
Amerikaner genauso und es ist nicht nur
eine moralische Frage sondern gerade bei
Amerikanern sieht man auch wie es ganz
konkret die eigene
Handlungsfähigkeit doch auch einschränkt
weil man eben selbst mit vermeintlich
verlässlichen Verbündeten in der Region
einfach nicht mehr Gehör findet weil die
Botschaft der Amerikaner auch in dieser
Woche von Anthony blinken an die
arabischen Verbündeten war immer sorgt
doch ihr mal mit euren mit eurem
Einfluss und euren Kontakten davor dass
die Situation in der Region nicht
eskaliert und ganz grob gesagt kriegt er
da jetzt als bestenfalls stöt sowas aus
Unverständnis und ich glaube man muss
diese Perspektive auch wenn man sie
nicht teilt man muss sie verstehen damit
man darauf reagieren kann und ich glaube
wenn das nicht geschieht dann wird man
sich dort auch aus westlicher Sicht
alleine wiederfinden und dann steht man
eben auch vielleicht vor einem
Horrorszenario gerade ein Horrorszenario
übrigens für die die Israelis dass man
äh diese ganzen Beziehung die man auch
zu arabischen Staaten in den letzten
Jahren aufgebaut hat auch verliert und
einer viel größeren Front äh auch
vielleicht gegensteht mhm sie haben
jetzt den Westen und die USA gerade
schon angesprochen sowohl der Westen
also auch die USA gehören zu Westen
logischerweise aber auch die
Bundesregierung und europäische Staaten
die sehen sich in den vergangenen Wochen
immer wieder mit dem Vorwurf
konfrontiert dass sie eigentlich keinen
Plan haben wie es im Gazakrieg und in
der Region weitergehen soll wenn man ihn
jetzt so zuhört wiederholt sich da
möglicherweise gerade dieser Fehler wenn
man das so bezeichnen möchte am Roten
Meer ja es spiegelt natürlich ähnliche
grundversäumnisse wieder auch dass man
ähm dass man eben anscheinend nicht in
der Lage ist auch bestimmte Perspektiven
Sichtweisen aus der Region irgendwie zu
akzeptieren und darauf und darauf
einzugehen äh und natürlich sieht sieht
man in der Region auch dass auch die
westlichen Verbündeten vergleichsweise
wenig Einfluss z.B auf die israelische
Regierung haben die ja ihre Verbündeten
immer wieder auflaufen lässt also sowohl
Anthony blinken als auch annalina
berburg werden da ja fast ignoriert mit
ihren mit ihren aufrufen auch und ihren
Bemühung auch z.B humanitäre Lage zu
verbessern das
heißt in der Region wird das so gesehen
ihr ihr haltet uns an dafür zu sorgen
dass die Lage nicht eskaliert aber ihr
selber habt noch nicht mal Einfluss auf
diese israelische Regierung sich in
irgendeine irgendeine Richtung zu
bewegen während diese israelische
Regierung eben Fakten schafft und und so
ein Gebiet wie Gase großflächig zerstört
und die Rückkehr von Millionen Menschen
verunmöglicht das und in dieser Form ist
z.B wird z.B Deutschland auch gar nicht
mal so sehr als eine passive Partei
gesehen sondern tatsächlich auch gerade
in dieser Ereigniskette und auch anhand
der Äußerung als eine aktive Partei
Konfliktpartei auf Seiten der Netanyahu
Regierung und ich glaube da
da ist ein da ist ein ganz großer ganz
große Gefahr für Deutschland aber auch
für andere westliche Länder nicht nur in
diesem
nicht nur in diesem Konflikt auch wenn
es um andere Konflikte geht z.B gerade
im Sudan ein ganz schlimmer Konflikt
auch auch auch da
hunderttausende vertriebene Opfer dort
wenn man dort Einfluss haben will oder
auch in allen anderen Konflikten wenn
man etwa auch im ukrainekrieg den
globalen Süden auf seine Seite ziehen
will was unerlässig ist um diese
sanktionsumgehung der Russen z.B zu
umgehen braucht man braucht man dort
diese Region und man verliert diese
Region gerade her hat die dann lassen
Sie uns abschließend vielleicht noch
einmal den Blick auf die Situation auf
die verherende Situation im Jemen
richten da ist seit 8 Jahren Krieg laut
uniceef ist die Ernährungssituation
heute so dramatisch wie nie zuvor
dreiviertel der Bevölkerung sein auf
humanitäre Lage angewiesen welche
Verantwortung tragen die husis daran und
was verändert sich dadurch durch die
aktuellen Entwicklung und kämpfe ja die
husis tragen natürlich maßgeblich
verantwortlich Verantwortung dafür ger
natürlich in erster Linie in den
Gebieten die unter ihrer Kontrolle sind
nun ist nicht der gesamte Jemen unter
der Kontrolle der huthis aber sie haben
auf jeden Fall in den letzten Jahren
schon in vielen Gebieten so die Oberhand
gewonnen und sie beherrschen natürlich
auch die jemenitische Hauptstadt Sana
etwa und nicht nur das sondern sie
kontrollieren auch ganz viele der der
Zugänge am Meer der der heäfen und
darüber kommt ja z.B auch humanitäre
unterstüt Stützung gerade aus
un-beständen und diese kritik gibt's
schon seit Jahren das im Prinzip
diese husis es geschafft haben ähnlich
etwa wie auch das syrische Regime dort
die die die Hilfslieferung und das Leid
der Menschen zu dem eigenen Vorteil zu
drehen und dass man darauf keine Antwort
gefunden hat andererseits gab es im
letzten Jahr doch schon Hoffnung und ich
finde auch durchaus berechtigte Hoffnung
dass dort dass dort irgendwelche
Fortschritte gibt nachdem sich die
Saudis unter welchen Umständen auch
immer dazu entschlossen haben uns ist
als übergeordnetes Ziel Stabilität in
der Region für unsere Investitionen
wichtiger und deswegen beißen wir auch
in den Sauen Apfel und verhandeln mit
mit diesen mit diesen hthis das heißt
nicht dass dieser Frieden automatisch
auch die Lage der Zivilbevölkerung
human bessert aber klar auch ohne ohne
ohne eine grundliegende Verbesserung der
politischen
Rahmenbedingungen macht ist auch jede
humanitäre Hilfe immer anfällig dafür
instrumentalisiert zu werden und auch
gezielt teilweise auch gegen eine
Bevölkerung eingesetzt zu werden sagt
Robert chati er ist eine ausexperte und
stellvertretender Chefredakteur des
Magazins Zenit vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
und für die Einschätzung heute Abend
gerne soweit unser ZDF heute live zu den
Angriffen der USA und Großbritanniens
Aufstellungen der hui Miliz im jeemen
und zur Situation am Roten Meer wenn ihr
dazu aktuelle Entwicklung haben möchtet
oder Hintergründe dann findet ihr die
wie immer in unserer ZDF heute App danke
euch für heute fürs zuschauen für eure
Fragen und bis zum nächsten
[Musik]
Mal